I'm standing in front of one of the most
infamous man-made structures in the
world in some places it's as high as
eight meters making it twice the height
of the Berlin Wall
it runs 280 miles long basically the
distance between Philadelphia and Boston
has been under construction for the past
13 years and it's still not done
oh and according to the International
Court of Justice this wall is completely
illegal I'm in the occupied West Bank
where Palestinians have been living
under Israeli military occupation since
1967 the wall is one of the most
imposing parts of that occupation Israel
began building the wall in the early
2000s during a wave of suicide bombings
that targeted Israelis the Israeli
government calls it the separation
barrier or the security fence and says
the aim is to keep out Palestinian
attackers but thousands of Palestinians
still managed to get across everyday
looking for work so if the wall doesn't
stop people from crossing then what does
it do let's take a look at the root of
the wall you think a wall meant to stop
people from entering its territory would
be built on Israel's border but 85% of
it is inside the occupied West Bank on
Palestinian land international law says
it's illegal to build settlements like
these on occupied territory but this is
one of over 200 settlements and settler
outposts housing half a million Israelis
in the occupied West Bank technically
these settlers live outside of Israel
proper but the wall has shifted the
boundary between Israel and the West
Bank to swallow up more Palestinian land
when the wall is completed an area the
size of Chicago will have been added to
the Israeli side of the wall while
settlers who live west of the wall are
full Israeli citizens with rights and
benefits the Palestinians who live in
that same territory have none
this is the village of Taba near
qalqilya it's just one of many
Palestinian villages that lost at least
half of its land to the wall Israel used
dynamite to clear the path for the wall
damaging homes and at the local school
in some parts the wall is made of
concrete and in other parts it's fencing
depending on the proximity to
Palestinian homes I'm standing at a gate
that Israel only opens once a year to
allow villagers to harvest their olives
which was once their main source of
livelihood what happens when the wall
cuts right through a neighborhood this
entire Palestinian village called hizmet
has been walled off from the rest of
Jerusalem except for the homes of a
couple of Palestinian families that got
stuck on the Israeli side of the wall
and people here aren't even allowed to
go visit their old neighbors hismus
technically part of Jerusalem
meaning it's on Israel to provide the
villagers services like trash pickup and
security but it doesn't and the
villagers are basically forced to fend
for themselves do you think the biblical
city of Bethlehem would have a booming
tourism industry but here you can find
one of the clearest examples of how the
wall has devastated the Palestinian
economy many businesses have shutdowns
and families have left when it's
completed Bethlehem will be completely
cut off from its agricultural land its
churches and more the wall along with a
series of illegal Israeli settlements
are physically strangling the city and
it can't expand and because of the wall
most Palestinians coming from Bethlehem
cannot take this road to nearby
Jerusalem you can only get through this
checkpoint if you have a special permit
which most Palestinians can't get
[Music]
so there you have it this wall a fixture
of the occupation has destroyed
neighborhoods strangled the economy and
illegally grabbed more Palestinian land
Palestinians call it the apartheid wall
and the question is how long will it
stand
[Music]
you